normalerweise stehen die chemie kann
natürlich nicht am liebsten vor der
kamera sondern richtig in der küche
[Musik]
wir backen heute dieses video ist
gewinnt mit unserer grafikerin melanie
die da eigener aussage nicht backen kann
deswegen backen wir heute eines der
einfachsten sachen die man machen kann
nämlich butterplätzchen und zu
demonstrieren wie einfach es ist habe
ich mir heute zwei kleine helfer hier
geholt und ihr bank gleich warum sie
butterplätzchen so einfach weil wir es
hier mit einem mehr beteiligt zu tun
haben da muss man nichts beachten außer
dass alle zutaten reinkommen und zwar
500 gramm mehl 200 gramm zucker 375
gramm butter vier mal halb so das mehl
ist natürlich die basis beim backen
das besondere bei mehlis ist besteht
nicht nur aus kohlenhydraten sondern
auch aus proteinen vor allem aus dem
berüchtigten kienbaum mag mich kein und
warum seid ihr so gemein zudem
produzieren wenn ihr keine echte
unverträglichkeit habt hat es keinen
sinn darauf zu verzichten blut hin setzt
sich zusammen aus zwei protein klassen
den green und den blutigen die erst
zusammenfinden wenn man wasser hinzu
gibt und sich dann verbinden eine art
kleber bilden deswegen nennt man gluten
auch das kleber protein sehr wichtig
beim brotbacken wo man eben auch viel
wasser hat für diese konsistenz die sind
chinas wir wollen hier nicht wir wollen
ja nur teig deswegen haben wir auch
generell wenig wasser in unserem rezept
wir haben nur wasser aus der butter die
besteht aus maximal 16 prozent wasser
und den eigen
das besteht so zur hälfte aus wasser
mutter besteht natürlich zu großem teil
aus fett was ein hervorragender
geschmacksträger ist und sowieso für den
geschmack bei butterplätzchen essentiell
ist aber sie sorgt auch dafür dass die
plätze in eben nicht steinhart werden
bei einem kuchen will jetzt das feld
also die butter und den zucker erstmal
schaumig schlagen für den fluss das
brauchen wir auch nicht ist alles ganz
easy bei ca zucker ist ein sehr
interessantes material beim backen die
offensichtliche funktion von zucker ist
natürlich das ist süß schmeckt aber
zucker hat auch noch andere funktionen
zum beispiel ist der mikroskopisch das
heißt erzielte wasser an sich ihr werdet
also feststellen wenn ihr deutlich
weniger zucker benutzt in eurem rezept
dann werden eure plätzchen schneller
trocken während beim lagern und zucker
geht eine sehr sehr wichtige reaktion
einiger offen dazu kommen wir später als
letztes haben wir ist gilt rezepte die
mutter fehlt sind auch mit ganzem ein
machen das kann man machen ist jetzt
nicht weiter schlimm ist oder vielleicht
nicht ganz real weiß zu fast 90 prozent
aus wasser besteht und wir wollen halt
beim beteiligt ein relativ festen
dichten zeigt und nicht so viel wasser
die hauptbestandteile von eigelb sind
etwa die hälfte wasser ca 30 prozent
fett und circa 15 bis 16 prozent
proteine das heißt eiweiß enthält auch
eiweiß und nicht nur das eigene enthält
mehr weiß als weiß wenn ihr also freunde
hab di gern ins fitnessstudio gehen und
eiweiß am netz essen dann hat es vor
allem kalorien technisch vorteile weil
es eben fast nur aus wasser besteht mehr
proteine sind aber tatsächlich im eigelb
und diese proteine sind eben auch
wichtig beim backen im ofen dazu von mir
gleich aber jetzt müssen wir einfach
alles zusammen kippen reihenfolge ist
relativ egal
also holen jetzt unsere bank helfer um 2
die bereiche und gehe
[Musik]
der teig muss jetzt eine stunde lang
kühlschrank titeln den leuten
[Musik]
im ofen passierende folgende sachen die
butter schmilzt das heißt sie plätzchen
weiten sich ein bisschen das wasser
verdampft das heißt die kätzchen gehen
ein bisschen auf und die proteine aus
den eiern die man sich bei
raumtemperatur wie solange
zusammengeknüllte schüler oder einzelne
wolk neues vorstellen muss und knollen
sich jetzt bei hohen temperaturen dieses
and kneule nennt man die natur ihren und
führt dazu dass sich die lang fäden
miteinander verheddern und so ein
dreidimensionales netzwerk bilden das
den teig zusammenhält und es passiert so
ab 140 grad einen der besten chemischen
reaktion überhaupt die wahl reaktion
dabei reagieren zucker und aminosäuren
zu ringförmigen molekülen wie das nicht
so reflektieren dass man diese schöne
braune farbe hat das heißt wenn dem
rezept print steht waren bis die
plätzchen gold frauen sind heißt es auf
chemisch backen bis die maya reaktion
stattgefunden hat die malaria zum
passiert auch beim kaffee rösten oder
beim fleisch braten eigentlich überall
wo irgendwas braun und aromatisch wird
und bildet eben eine ganze bandbreite an
wohlriechenden geschmacks und
aromastoffe juni hat ein
wasserspielplatz gemacht ok dann kann
man die plätzchen auch schon raus holen
und das machen was am meisten spaß macht
nämlich das skizzieren
wenn ihr gerne backt oder auf der suche
nach neuen rezeptideen seid dann schaut
doch mal bei living the health vorbei
ansonsten wenn ich das video gefallen
hat dann lasst es uns wissen in dem uns
einen daumen oben geht dann gibt es
vielleicht mal ein paar 2 mit kuchen das
nämlich auch viel mehr chemie drin
ansonsten 123
[Musik]
annika abonnieren